one of the biggest factors in our
happiness and well-being is the strength
and quality of our relationships most of
us want to find lasting love it's a
basic human need but it can be really
tough to find a romantic partner and
then you have to make that relationship
work but we often think that love and
romance are things that occur naturally
either a relationship works or it
doesn't and couples face a lot of
challenges like miscommunication
handling arguments and making big
decisions it can be so easy for our
emotions to get the better of us so we
say and do things that we regret
damaging our relationships and it can be
hard to know exactly what to do to make
your relationship ship stronger but it
turns out that there are some simple
evidence-based steps that you can take
to improve your relationship so that you
can build a healthy happy life with your
partner and so today we're going to be
hearing from doctors John and Julie Gman
they world-renowned experts and
researchers in relationships and a lot
of their work focuses on the way in
which couples interact with each other
and can actually go on to predict
divorce based on uh the couples that we
studied and there were over 3,000 of
them uh we now can help people by uh
creating interven ions which we've done
to change how people relate to one
another if it's not working in order to
really help couples succeed in the
future in their relationship so Dr John
and Dr Julie are going to talk us
through some of the common mistakes that
we make in relationships then they'll
chat about how we can change how we talk
to one another and there will be tips
and tricks for diffusing anger and
tension and then finally some techniques
that you can use to really bond with
your partner so in this first section
we're going to talk about some of the
mistakes that we make in relationships
and we're going to specifically look at
ways in which men misunderstand women
and the way women misunderstand men and
this can lead to significant conflict
what are some of the men specific advice
that you would give let's say if I was
if if if I was asking you hey you know
what are the common mistakes that men
tend to make in relationships and then
we can talk later about what are the
common mistakes that women tend to make
in relationships what does what does
that divide look like well first of all
men know that women have a cycle right
so they have a menstrual cycle that's
happening regularly every month and I
don't think men understand so well uh
what happens to women when all those
hormones are flooding their bodies from
that menstrual cycle what can happen um
there's more fluid accumulated in the
body due to hormonal changes and that
fluid affects all of the body the brain
included and the woman typically will
become more sensitive so she'll be more
sensitive emotionally
she may take things uh a little harder
so you've got to watch that kind of
Swing of moods and not necessarily
believe that some of the stuff that she
says a few days before her period is
exactly how she feels another thing is
to realize that women typically see ways
to improve the relationship they're
always watching for is this a good
relationship is it loving enough am I
being listened to
Etc uh and so they'll bring up issues
more commonly than men men can kind of
Coast on yeah this is this is fine this
is okay uh but women tend not to and so
they're going to bring up issues more
regularly that can make men feel like
whatever I do it's not enough and that's
one of the things women have to be
sensitive to in men so men are trying
very hard to be the best husbands they
can be the best fathers they can be and
they're working hard at it and sometimes
they may not understand what a woman
needs for example if a woman comes home
stressed from her work the man thinks as
he listens to her that he should offer
her a solution to whatever she's
stressed about
wrong that's going to feel condescending
to the woman because it's another way of
saying you're not smart enough to figure
out a solution so let me give you one
right that's the message she may take
from it the thing that men need to do in
that situation is to not offer Solutions
unless the woman has specifically asked
for that and
instead just listen to what she's saying
try to feel a little bit of what she's
expressing ask her questions like what's
the most upsetting part about this for
you or help me understand how this made
you feel so anxious I want to I want to
really get inside that and know that um
and then give words of empathy and
empathy is going to look like no wonder
you felt so angry wow yeah I would have
been upset too that sounds terrible so
you're really stepping into the
partner's World emotionally and hanging
out in there with her um empathizing
with her so she doesn't feel so alone
with those feelings not feeling alone is
the big stress reducer not getting a
solution to a problem you mentioned
earlier when we were talking that
recently you've done a lot of research
on gay and lesbian couples I wonder
what's been some of the surprising
things that you found from that research
I guess compared to heterosexual couples
yeah one of the things that we that we
discovered is that gay and lesbian
couples are a lot less defensive when
their partner presents a point of view
than male female relationships so we
have a lot to learn from those
relationships you know we think well you
know since you know they're they're the
minority their relationships you know
they're not the the majority
relationships then there must be
something wrong with them something
defective we found in fact that in many
ways they were Superior to heterosexual
relationships it wasn't as much War the
way it is between men and women and you
know and they didn't get into these
standoffs they would you know they
basically would say oh well that's an
interesting point of view let's talk
about your point of view and you know
here's what I think you're saying and is
that right you know so they were just
much better communicators and that was
really interesting to discover one of
the biggest biggest biggest most
important differences between men and
women in heterosexual relationships it's
about sex the biggest difference is that
women need emotional closeness in order
to be open sexually
men typically don't they may use sex as
a way to feel emotionally close women
have a history of thousands of years of
being raped sexually abused hurt through
sex we feel it in our bones even if we
haven't experienced it ourselves we
don't feel safe in the world you can
take a room of people give them an
example of you're walking into a
underground garage how many of you feel
afraid almost all the women will raise
their hands almost none of the men will
so when a woman is being most vulnerable
which is typically during sexual
intimacy she really needs to feel safe
particularly if she's had any kind of
sexual abuse in background and we know
that at the minimum one out of four
women by the age of 18 has experience
sexual abuse or molestation and it's
those are the only ones who report it
it's probably a higher percentage than
that so women need to feel emotionally
close in order to be sexually open we
need as women we need to understand that
for men a lot of times you know men may
feel like oh it's too childlike to just
ask for a cuddle so we'll be manly and
we'll go for sex which gives us you know
all the touch and all the hugging and
you know all that contact that we need
as well as pleasure so um women need to
understand that uh their men are looking
for emotional closeness through sex and
to be as giving as they can
next up we're going to talk about some
of John and Julie's Research into the
reasons why relationships fail and they
call these The Four Horsemen of
relationship failure these are the four
things that we do which can alienate our
partners and lead to unhappiness so
these are the great big predictors uh
that can predict with over 90% accuracy
six years down the road where are you
going to be you're going to be together
happily with your partner unhappily or
will you already be separated and
divorced so the first one is criticism
and all of us are familiar with that one
there's no such thing as constructive
criticism none so when your boss tries
to yeah when your boss tries to
critically uh tell you feedback that's
not a good thing so what criticism means
is blaming a problem between you on a
character flaw of your partner so some
examples of that are you're so lazy you
wouldn't think of cleaning up the
kitchen why are you so uh irresponsible
you're always postponing how long it
takes to pay the bills you know what's
happening with you what's wrong with you
is one of the great criticisms how are
you supposed to answer that you know
it's saying you in general are wrong so
those are criticisms and they hurt and
the natural response to that is the
second Horseman called defensiveness and
defensiveness we're familiar with too
there's two types one is whining like I
did to pay the bills on time or
Counterattack oh yeah well when was the
last time you took the car in for repair
you know it's a Counterattack so that's
defensiveness we have criticism
defensiveness the third is really the
sulfuric acid for a relationship it's
called contempt and what we mean my
contempt is it's criticism too but from
a place of moral superiority so it
includes some scorn some disgust it's
often expressed through
sarcasm um like oh yeah I'm sure you
picked up the tickets ha you know
contempt uh is also name calling all
those horrible names when we get very
angry that we'll call somebody could be
mockery
also o You're so scared you know that
kind of stuff um so contempt is horrible
and it not only is the strongest
predictor of relationship demise
contempt also destroys the immune system
of the listener we discovered that in 15
minutes of conflict the number of times
a listener heard something contemptuous
predicted how many infectious illnesses
they would have in the coming years
right isn't that amazing so the immune
system suppresses of course or fights
off viruses colds flues tumors tumors
right and the people who experience more
contempt got sicker over time so that
was scary finally the fourth Horseman is
what we call
stonewalling and stonewalling is when
one partner completely shuts down
absolutely gives no response to the
person pretends they're not even there
we'll sit there but not give any knot of
the head anything verbal and uh that's
related to another Finding of ours about
uh physiological flooding which John can
explain right so the the physiology was
very predictive and what we found was
that when people's heart rate gets above
100 beats a minute or if you're an
athlete 80 beats a minute we start
secreting our two stress hormones
cortisol and adrenaline and that shuts
down the ability to listen people repeat
themselves they think they're being more
persuasive when they yell instead of you
know talking quietly they you know they
really escalate their behavior and they
can't listen very well they can't take
in any new information so the physiology
is very important because once people
are secreting those two stress hormones
they you know the conversation might as
well be over because it nobody makes any
advanced they don't get creative as
problem solvers and so on yeah another
word for this is fight or flight so when
you're facing your partner it feels like
you're facing a sabertooth tiger so in
that context let's say you're in the
middle of a I don't know an argument
with your partner and you're finding
yourself feeling those triggers of fight
or flight what does success and what
does fail look like like what what what
are the kind of options that we have in
this in this context so fail looks like
staying there in the conversation when
you're in fight ORF flight uh and what
happens is you escalate you get louder
you repeat yourself you know ad nauseum
you start to move into more criticism
more contempt you can't think straight
you don't hear your partner at all so
nothing you say is a response to your
partner you're just yelling your own
point of view maybe maybe even getting
physical in the worst cases in a
successful couple here's what they do
the minute they sense that they're
getting flooded in fight or flight one
of them will call for a break and and
say when they ask for a break when
they'll come back to talk about the
conversation you know that topic again
so they'll say something like honey I
I've got to take a break I'll be back in
an hour then let's talk again that way
they don't leave the other person
feeling abandoned and not knowing if
they're ever going to talk about it
again then when the partners separate
into separate
quarters uh they each do something that
is self
soothing not think about the fight
because if they think about it they'll
stay escalated but do something else
distract yourself read a magazine a book
listen to music meditation go for a run
you know all kinds of things you can do
to self soothe take a bath and then come
back at the designated time when you're
calmer and a way to tell if you're
calmer is take your heart rate and if
your heart rate is back down to normal
then you're good if it's not back go
back to your partner anyway and ask for
more time give a second time you'll
return until you can talk calmly with
one another and the conversation will
look like you've just had a brain
transplant now John and Julie also have
some really practical advice on how to
cool down from a conflict with your
partner you can then return to the
conversation in a healthier and more
relaxed frame of mind this is super
useful every single couple has arguments
and disagreements but the most important
thing is to change the way we handle
those difficult conversations so we can
grow together instead of growing apart
we we talked about the four horsemen
let's say someone's listening to this or
watching this and they're thinking oh
damn you know I'm I've definitely got
some of one or more of those in my
relationship what are the actions that
someone can take if they recognize that
their relationship is sort of falling
into one of these four horsemen well one
of the best things uh that you can do um
we call processing a regrettable
incident now here's what that means um
this is a particular Intervention when
you've had a really bad fight where some
of those four horsemen have thundered
through the
conversation um it's really important to
go back with your partner and talk about
what happened in the in the way that you
communicated what went wrong in the way
you communicated and then apologize for
it and we have a five-step process for
this where each person names their
feelings that they had during the
regrettable incident then they narrate
their point of view about what
transpired and needless to say there's
always two points of view and they could
feel like they're on opposite planets
but they're both valid they're both
right so each one presents their point
of view the other one summarizes what
they just heard the partner say and
gives a few words of validation like I
get it I can see how you would have felt
that way and then third they talk about
what may have gotten triggered for them
and triggers mean feelings that come up
for you during a fight or regrettable
incident that are the same feelings you
may have had long before this
relationship that may have started in
childhood or in a former
relationship and those in can include
things like abandonment rejection
feeling judged um feeling
frightened those kinds of old feelings
you've been carrying inside you your
whole life perhaps so you talk about
those triggers and what stories go with
those from your past you share one of
those so your partner really understands
better the scars that you carry inside
from old
experiences uh and can try to avoid
triggering those and then the fifth step
is to talk about one thing you can do
differently and one thing your partner
can do differently to avoid some like
this from happening
again that's how you process a
regrettable incident how long afterwards
should you would you recommend waiting
to process a regrettable incident
whenever as long as it's not immediately
afterwards so some people won't know
they're supposed to do this and then
they'll go back and process something 20
years later 15 years later the way that
you know you need to process it is that
it still festers in your mind when you
think about it that means you need to
process it but with that said you have
to be very calm when you sit down in
process and I like to tell people
imagine that you're in the upper balcony
of a theater after act one of a play
that play down on stage was the two of
you fighting and you're talking to your
partner about what happened during act
one that's the kind of calmness you need
to have before you talk
to what extent is there utility in
talking things out at the time so can
you talk about it immediately afterwards
is that what you're asking it's not yeah
I guess you what do you do while the
while the emotions are still like still
they're not quite at that calm level
where you can discuss it fully calmly I
wouldn't do it because it's so easy to
slide into the old argument again you'll
slide right back into the fight um and
also a lot of people will apologize
almost immediately and that doesn't work
either and the reason is because you
haven't heard your partner's experience
of the fight enough to know how your
behavior impacted them so you don't
really know what you're apologizing for
until you've heard the story of your
partner's experience and you've been
able to share yours too because usually
both people in some way are responsible
for what happen not always but often
finally we're going to discuss some of
the tools that you can use to build
strength and intimacy with your partner
now there's this idea that things should
just be natural and they can be but the
truth is that there are real steps you
can take to make sure your relationship
stays loving and close as you move
through life this is one of my favorite
things to do Ali is to create what we
call rituals of connection and rituals
of connection are activities that you do
together with your partner that are
pre-designed they're pre-planned and
they're agreed upon so you co-design a
ritual of connection so for example the
way that you greet each other first
thing in the morning when you wake up
the way that you greet each other if
you're working you know apart and you
reunite at the end of the day do you
typically go out on a date one night a
week or do you go out for brunch every
Sunday so John and I have this great
ritual after dinner we have what we call
a cuddle couch and um we'll watch
British murder mysteries in the evening
when cuddle and cuddle and you know
we're squished together our dog often
joins us so he's in there too and uh
we'll watch you know rich people getting
murdered and it's very satisfying
so um that's a ritual of connection
that's a ritual of connection rituals of
connection ction can be big too they can
be how are birthdays celebrated in our
family how are the religious holidays
celebrated in our family what kind of
vacations do you go on um we have an
annual honeymoon that we do right and we
we rent the same room uh so for 23 years
we've been taking about 10 days bring
our kayak and and we sit and talk to
each other for those 10 days about what
was the year like what did you hate
about last year what did you love about
last year and what do you want next year
to be like and we take a lot of time to
really do that while we're having fun
kaying and hiking and eating out in
really good restaurants and going to the
Farmers Market on Saturday and things
like that so that's one of our rituals
of connection that we love that sounds
that sounds amazing um one of the one of
the things that my partner and I started
doing fairly early on in our
relationship it's it's been about 18
months now um we read a book called how
to not die alone by Logan Yuri and in
the book she talked about doing uh
relationship reviews and these included
these questionnaires and so almost from
kind of day one we've been doing every
few weeks a relationship review and
everyone I'm all my friends I mentioned
this to like half of them say oh my gosh
that I I need that in my life and the
other half say wait what that's that's a
bit weird how can he possibly do a
relationship review um but it's been one
of the most worthwhile Parts about kind
of growing together because we co-
decided on what 10 questions we were
going to use we have a little notion
template that we've been filling in
since for the last 18 months I mean i'
i' I've I've certainly found it super
helpful to be like hey you know how are
you feeling what's something that I did
that maybe made you feel bad that I
didn't realize would make you feel bad
and it's been such a great kind of
learning curve from from my end but also
those little things that feel like
they're not worth bringing up in the
moment we always know that okay at some
point in the next couple of weeks we're
going to sit down and actively talk
about stuff so you know if it doesn't
need if it's not a major thing that
needs to be discussed right now it's it
can always be pushed to to the review do
you guys do anything like that is is
that is that something that you would
recommend people do yeah we totally do
we have um and we often uh say that our
clients should do this but we tell
everybody to do this uh it's called a
state of the union meeting the meeting
begins with each person giving three to
five
appreciations um for things the other
person has done
uh and saying thank you and these are
typically things that maybe haven't been
uh thanked for earlier so each person
gives each other these appreciations
then the middle of the meeting is
bringing up anything that they need to
solve any decisions that need to be made
any uh past regrettable incidents that
need to be processed the way we talked
about earlier today and then the meeting
ends with the question um that each
person poses to the other what is one
way that I can help you feel more loved
do you guys have a ritual around it do
you like go out for dinner and then do
it or is it is it like an ad hoc thing
that happens what's the context around
the state of the union meeting everybody
can create their own context right I
mean if you have six kids running around
the house you might want to go
out um uh if you don't you can do it at
home on a Sunday morning um you can
certainly go out to dinner you can do it
while you're taking a walk I mean that's
really a nice way to have that kind of
joining together and talking so you know
whatever you're comfortable with it's
similar to uh what we did in our book
eight dates where we created
conversations with uh a few questions
and preparation thinking you know things
to think about for each date and then
people discussing these deeper topics on
each date uh and we give suggestions for
what that date could look like given
that particular topic for the week um
and of course people have the freedom to
do whatever they want to do uh but it's
it's really you know a lovely thing to
do to talk about these deeper topics and
to have a way to do that I'd love to
talk a little bit about the new book uh
the love prescription seven days to more
intimacy connection and joy one of the
one of the claims in the book or or at
least in the in the blurb is that there
is a formula for a good relationship and
if you just I almost the vibe that I got
was that hey if you follow the formula
and just do these seven things across
these seven days or how however long it
takes you will just almost magically
improve the quality of your relationship
uh so I wonder if you can just kind of
Riff on that a little bit like what is
this for formula for love one of the
things is being nice to one another
what a so you know uh giving a partner
compliments uh catching a partner doing
something right and and communicating
that communicating respect and affection
in words letting your partner know how
attractive they are to you and how
irresistible they seem at times you know
those that kind of positivity is very
very critical another one is turning
toward is turns out to be a very
powerful thing in a relationship so you
know in our apartment lab where we saw
130 newlywed couples and followed them
for six years we discovered that a lot
of time when they're just kind of
hanging out in this apartment lab one
person will try to get the other
person's attention or share something
humorous or you know some interesting
story that they've heard or are reading
about and then they try to connect they
make a bid for connection and then the
cameras in the lab always swung to the
other person to see the response and
there were one of three responses
turning toward which was you know really
acknowledging the connection you know
one person might say Oh What a Beautiful
boat that is you know going by and if
the other person said yeah huh uh that
was turning toward if they didn't
respond at all that was turning away or
if they responded irritably will you be
quiet I'm trying to read that was
turning against
so we found couples the the 17 couples
who divorced one another after uh six
years after the wedding um when we look
back six six years earlier they had
turned toward these bids only 33% of the
time whereas the couples who were still
together six years earlier had turned
toward the bids 86% of the time you know
huge
difference and we also discovered that
turning toward is like an emotional bank
account that you build when you really
connect with your partner when your
partner wants to connect with you then
during conflict you have more of a sense
of humor about yourself and about one
another you can laugh together and you
can be affectionate even when you're
disagreeing and when people become aware
of that as a tool of connecting then the
relationship improves quite dramatically
right so in this book um what we're
doing is each
day we're giving couples little thing to
do little 10minute thing to do every
single day like one day we'll be giving
compliments you know really expressing
fondness and admiration a second day
will be look for what your partner is
doing
right and not just wrong right and point
it out and say thank you to your partner
you know third is listening you know
talking about your needs with one
another what do you need and we
emphasize you should bring up your needs
as a positive need rather than a
negative need and what that means is
that you ask for what you do want not
what you don't like or you resent don't
bring that up because that's going to
sound like criticism instead flip it on
its head and say I would love it if you
clean the dishes
three times a week that would be such a
big help to me so uh people present you
know on I forget which day they talk
about one need they have with their
partner that can allow their partner to
shine for them another one is honoring
each other's dreams so talk about what
maybe deeply held dream you have for
something you want to do something you
want to experience something you want to
feel whatever it is is share that with
your partner and really listen to what
your partner says about that question
too what we hope to see if people
practice this every day for seven days
is that from before they started it to
the end of the week they'll see a little
bit of change maybe little something
feels different and they can talk about
which one of those little prescriptions
really made a difference for them
now it doesn't mean everything gets
fixed in seven days and then you can go
back to being whoever you were before no
it's instead that you're learning how to
do something a little different that
deepens the Friendship deepens emotional
intimacy which of course opens up to you
know what you know more sexual
intimacy and helps you when you have to
talk about conflict continue those
practices especially the ones you found
the best for you and your partner and
you'll see over time you know the
relationship is doing this over time big
change I really hope you found this
episode useful these are all the
techniques that I use in my own
relationship and they really do make a
big difference thank you so much for
watching